et autour de ce qui reste des tours
jumelles dès mardi une zone de sécurité
a bien sûr été mise en place
mais aujourd'hui certains habitants de
ce quartier de manhattan à cause de la
colère de la douleur et de la fatigue
sont exaspérés il aspire au plus vite à
retrouver une vie presque normale sur
place le reportage de jean marc pitte et
pierre dick bien au delà du lieu de la
catastrophe
le sud de manhattan est devenu depuis
mardi une zone de sécurité interdite au
public les barrages de la police ont
transformé en désert ce quartier très
animé il ya une semaine encore les
habitants qui n'ont pas voulu le quitter
sont soumis en permanence à des
contrôles d'identité
vous vous sentez comme dans un ghetto
vous devez montrer votre carte
d'identité
un policier vous dit non vous ne pouvez
pas aller là-bas parce que cet immeuble
est abandonné alors je vais voir un
autre policier qui me dit ok tout ça
pour rentrer chez moi là où je être
quand je récupérerai ma vie mon
voisinage
quand j'aurai tous les mis en sécurité
quand les policiers enlèveront tout ça
quand les magasins rouvriront alors
seulement je me sentirai mieux les
nombreux restaurants du quartier n'ont
bien sûr plus de clients mais certains
comme celui fondé par robert de niro ont
décidé dès l'après midi du drame de
participer aux efforts de sauvetage
le très branché tribeca grill est ainsi
devenu un restaurant de collectivités
fournissant entre 1000 et 2000 repas par
jour aux pompiers aux policiers aux
volontaires qui lutte au milieu des
ruines
il était aussi heureux de se rendre
compte que quelqu'un s'occupe et de plus
quelqu'un tentait de les aider que du
fait de recevoir de la nourriture
sitôt ceo bacon terminée scott le chefs
de grands restaurants se transforme en
livreur pour apporter aux sauveteurs
leur petit déjeuner contrairement à nous
il est autorisé à pénétrer sur le site
de la catastrophe protéger cette fois
par l'armée pour leurs auteurs ses
nombreuses initiatives ont une
motivation commune a tous oublié cette
obsédante amas de tôle qui balafre la
ville et leur esprit il est actuellement
bien d'autres